let's go to number 12.
maximize your strengths minimize your
weaknesses i remember one time i was
having a conversation with a mentor a
number of years ago and he said
stop working on your weaknesses
i said emma why like why not like are we
supposed to improve our weaknesses no
all you're gonna have is really good
weaknesses and he was right
honestly um i found i
i caught myself doing it on myself i
caught myself trying to train
staff out of their weaknesses and he was
right all people end up with
is really strong weaknesses if you try
to maximize your weaknesses
what he's saying here in point number 12
is maximize your strengths
minimize your weaknesses this goes for
the entirety
of anybody when it comes to attraction
somebody will
will say well i'm only five foot seven
and all women want guys over six foot
tall blah blah blah wow
they start crying about it okay that's
your weakness there's nothing you can do
about it you're gonna minimize that
be five foot seven with muscles and
money right and wicked tight gain
simple as that so point number 12
maximize your strengths minimize your
weaknesses
in the betterment of ourselves as men we
attract women into our orbit to
accomplish this gravitational pull as
painlessly
and efficiently as possible you must
identify your natural talents
shortcomings and parcel your efforts
accordingly
if you're a gifted jokester don't waste
time and energy trying to raise your
status
in physic physiological i can't
pronounce that word right now debate
if you write well but dance poorly don't
kill yourself trying to expand your
manly influence on the dance floor
that's me i can't dance for unless
i'm drunk and even that i'm not sure
what's going on i just feel like i'm
dancing great
your goal should be to attract women
effortlessly so play to your strengths
no matter what they
are there's a groupie for every male
endeavor except world of warcraft
well he's wrong about that one this is
the first point well not even the first
point the first
sentence it's just four words there that
i disagree with and i know this because
i used to play this dorky game
many many moons ago when it first came
out and there are
uh groupies four men in world of
warcraft believe it or not they have
these guilds and these dorky girls who
are not attractive at all and quite
plump and rotund
uh we'll try to you know get the
attention and interest of these dorky
guys
on warcraft i was there i saw it happen
he was wrong about that one thing
uh there's a groupie for every male
endeavor in fact we should just end
and that point at this point and we'll
cut off this over here
so that's the only correction i would
make
you